>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> So hello, good afternoon,
my name is Tracy North.
I am a reference librarian
in the Hispanic Division
and Social Sciences
Editor of the "Handbook
of Latin American Studies",
an annotated guide
to scholarly publications
about Latin America
that has been published since 1936
and includes quite a few
references to baseball I might add.
So, on behalf of the Library of
Congress I am excited to welcome you
to today's talk by journalist
and author Cesar Brioso
about his new book "Havana
Hardball: Spring Training,
Jackie Robinson and
the Cuban League".
Do you know how many
Cubans are playing
in Major League Baseball today?
Do you know who was the first
Cuban to play in the MLB and when?
Have you heard of New York
Yankees' closer Aroldis Chapman
who was traded from the Reds
last year and is rumored to be
on the verge of getting
traded again?
He had a great night against my
Baltimore Orioles the other night,
routinely throwing
100-mile-an-hour fastballs.
Today, you will learn about some
of the historical foundations
of Cuban baseball on the island
with a focus on 1946 and 1947.
You'll learn about the rivalry
between the Almendares and Habana,
similar to rivalries
between the New York Yankees
and the Brooklyn Dodgers
of Jackie Robinson's era
or there is Boca Juniors versus
River Plate in Argentine soccer,
Barcelona versus Real Madrid
in Spain, Borg versus McEnroe,
Chrissie versus Martina
in tennis in the 80s.
You get the idea.
As you may know the Library
of Congress now holds the
Jackie Robinson Papers.
Preparing for his major league debut
with the Brooklyn Dodgers Robinson
participated in spring training
with the team in Cuba in 1947.
The idea was that he would be able
to avoid the attention of the press
and unsupportive fans in Florida,
the team's usual spring
training location.
At that time remember we're talking
about pre-revolutionary Cuba.
Robinson was not the first or only
American in Cuba during that time.
Think Hemingway whose
birthday is today by the way,
Sinatra, Meyer Lansky et cetera.
These are just some of the topics
that you'll hear more about today
from Cesar Brioso, a digital
producer for USA Today's sports
where he served as baseball
editor from 2003 to 2004.
Cesar has been a writer or editor
at several other papers
including The Miami Herald,
South Florida Sun Sentinel
and Tampa Tribune.
He's a member of the Society
for American Baseball Research
that's having their conference
coming up next week in
Florida and he blogs
about Cuban baseball
history at cubanbaseball,
spelled in Spanish, dot.com.
Now I'd like to turn the
program over to Cesar.
>> Thank you, good afternoon.
Thank you all for coming and thank
you to the Library of Congress
for letting me talk about
my book "Havana Hardball".
And so broadly, the book
is about baseball in Cuba
in the mid to late 1940s.
It's a pivotal time in baseball
history when Cuba finds itself
at the epicenter of
events that are going
to impact not just the Cuban League
but also other Latin leagues,
Major League Baseball and the
Negro Leagues for years to come.
I chose to focus on this
particular time period at least
in part because of my father.
You'll see a photo of him here.
That's him as a kid in Cuba
with one of his uncles.
He, the hat he's wearing
is Almendares, one of the.
That's his favorite team,
one of the four teams
in the Cuban League at that time.
Like when I was a kid my dad
would tell me all these stories
about American ball players who
would come to Cuba every winter
to play baseball and you're
seeing some of the photos up here.
You know familiar names, Tommy
Lasorda who became a Hall
of Fame manager with the
Dodgers, future Hall of Famers
from the Negro League like
Monte Irvin and Ray Dandridge
and as you're seeing right
here a guy named Kevin Connors
who you would be more familiar
with the name Chuck Connors
from the, Hollywood actor.
He was, before he became
a Hollywood actor
in "The Rifleman" he was a player
in the Dodgers Farm System.
So I'd hear all these stories
as I was a kid and then as,
once I became a sports writer
working in Florida I started
to find a lot of these guys
retired and in, throughout the state
and I would interview them for
stories for the various papers
that I worked for at the
time and started building,
collecting all these
interviews with the idea
of eventually, someday
writing a book.
And when I finally got a
publisher, sort of the last stage
of my research was the Library
of Congress, was very helpful.
They have a great collection of
Cuban newspapers on microfilm.
I was able to access those, not just
here but what was really helpful was
that the Library of Congress was
gracious enough to allow them
to be sent to Fairfax County Library
where I live which made research
so much easier not having to come
into the District multiple times
to be able to look
through all those articles.
That's broadly what
the book is about.
Specifically it focuses on the
1946-47 Cuban League season.
That is what is still
considered kind
of the greatest finish
in league history.
It came down to a three-game series
between Almandares and Habana,
the eternal rivals
as they were called.
Both teams had been in the Cuban
League since its formation in 1878,
just two years after the start of
the National League here in the U.S.
And as the three games, the decisive
three-game series was being played
out the Dodgers arrived for
spring training in Havana
and with them came their Triple
AAA Farm Team, the Montreal Royals
which included not only Jackie
Robinson but also Roy Campanella,
Don Newcombe and Roy Partlow.
And so the book alternates
between those two storylines
in alternating chapters and they
play out against the backdrop
of the Mexican League trying
to get major league players
to jump their contracts to
play in their summer league.
And why that matters
is because they,
them trying to get all these players
to jump, and in fact they got
like 20-something players
to jump their contracts.
Commissioner Happy Chandler
declared that any player
who jumped their contracts
would be ineligible
to play Major League Baseball
and organized baseball
for at least five years, and
even then there was no guarantee
that they'd be allowed back.
And that matters to the Cuban League
because so many players played
in the Cuban League of those jumpers
and Cuban players also played
in Mexico or managed or coached in
Mexico so Chandler had also declared
that anyone who played with
or against those jumpers
would also be ineligible
to play in organized baseball.
So in essence the Cuban League
which had enjoyed great relations
with Major League Baseball and had
players from the majors playing
in Cuba either in the league
or barnstorming really
throughout the 20th century,
they were suddenly a rogue league
and their players were rogue
players, just by playing
in the league were, their careers,
futures in organized
baseball were threatened.
So, and the book explores sort
of how all these conflicts came
into being, how they got resolved
and what happens going forward.
So, with that I think
I'll just open it up.
I'd prefer to have, it be more of a
conversation than me just standing
up here, kind of telling
you about the book
so hopefully you have
some interesting questions
and I'll be glad to answer them now.
Yes?
>> Since it was raised
in the introduction,
who was the first Cuban in the
Major League Baseball in America?
>> The very first Cuban in
the majors was Esteban Bellan
with the Detroit Haymakers in, I'm
trying to remember now off the top
of my head, 1870 something.
But in terms of the modern era
since 1900 there were a pair
of Cuban players signed by
the Cincinnati Reds in 1911,
Rafael Almeida and Armando Marsans.
So they joined in, like I said 1911
and when they were first signed
and were playing in the
minors there was this.
In my research I found
this sort of rushed by,
newspapers to assure baseball fans
that they were in fact, white,
really kind of amazing words used.
One, I believe the Cincinnati
Enquirer, if I remember correctly,
referred to them as the
two, two purest bars
of Castilian soap ever
sailed to these shores.
And there were all kinds
of, I mean that's kind
of how they were described.
Multiple newspaper accounts again
assuring white major league fans
that no, they're not black.
They're Cuban or they're of
you know European ancestry.
One referred to them as having
no ignoble African blood
so all these references in the 19,
the teens, trying to describe them
and assure fans they weren't black.
Yes? I'm sorry.
>> So what was the
racial situation in Cuba
in that summer that Jackie Robinson?
Were there any problems there?
>> No, not at all, in fact the
Cuban League had been integrated
since 1900 so they were far ahead
of integration here
in the major leagues.
In fact that's one of the
reasons why Branch Rickey chose
to move the Dodgers' spring
training from Daytona Beach.
That's where they trained
in 1946, to Havana.
They had been.
They were familiar with Havana.
They had trained there
in 1941 and 1942
and in '46 Robinson's first year
with the Royals they had a bunch
of issues trying to play games.
When the Royals would go to play a
minor league spring training game
they might find that the
stadium was padlocked
or that there was a sudden lighting
malfunction so they couldn't play.
In one instance a police officer
informed that there was an ordinance
where black and white players could
not share the same baseball field.
So they encountered all
these issues in 1946
so when Branch Rickey was planning
to make sure that that was the,
in '47, that that was the year
that he would elevate
Robinson to the Dodgers.
That's why he chose
to move to Havana
because of the better
racial climate certainly
in baseball and in society as well.
There were.
It's not to say that there's
no racism or no issues in Cuba
but it certainly was
not the codified racism
that you had here especially
in Florida with Jim Crow laws.
>> The ownership of the Cuban
League teams at that time,
was it pretty much all indigenous
ownership or was there any influence
of American owners or
investors down there?
>> No, it was pretty
much owned by Cubans.
In fact one of the sort of, baseball
legends Miguel Angel Gonzalez,
he played.
He was also one of the early
Cuban players in the majors.
He played in 1920s-30s.
He played with the Cardinals,
Giants, White Sox, several teams.
He was a catcher and
played with Habana most
of his career as a player.
He eventually became manager
of Habana, saved enough money
to become a part-owner and
eventually owned the entire team.
And that was pretty typical.
It was either individual,
Cuban individuals or a group
of Cubans who owned each team.
Almendares was owned by a group that
had ties to the Vedado Tennis Club
which was a social club for affluent
Cubans so that was pretty typical
of the teams in the Cuban League.
Yes?
>> Would you mind speaking sort
of generally about baseball
in Latin America and then
baseball introduction to Cuba?
How did it go from being this
game that we've all heard
about having its roots in
America and now we're talking
about Latin America and Cuba so?
>> Well, baseball was introduced
in Cuba around, in the 1860s.
Students who, Cuban students who
went to the United States to study
in college brought the game back
to Cuba in that time period.
It also kind of was helped
spread by the presence
of U.S. military in Cuba.
I've seen dozens of photos of U.S.
Navy teams playing in Guantanamo
in the early part of
the 20th century.
So, that's where it was first
introduced and it really became sort
of engrained in the Cuban
culture with the fight
for independence against Spain.
It became, sort of, one way
of expressing their rejection
of Spanish rule, choosing baseball
over bullfighting for example.
And it also became engrained as part
of that with the exiled communities
in Key West, Ybor City in Tampa.
They would form their own social
clubs here in the United States
and they would put on baseball
games and some of the proceeds
from those games would be sent
back to Cuba to fight the,
for the fight for independence.
So in the late 1800s it really
started to become entrenched
and be part of Cuban culture,
what it means to be Cuban.
And then Cuba really
became sort of the apostles
of baseball throughout
the Caribbean,
spreading it to other countries.
There were some people who left
Cuba to, you know because of the war
to places like Mexico and the
Dominican Republic for safety
and kind of brought the game
there with them then and it built
up through that, that way.
>> Can you take that one step
further to then integrating
into Major League Baseball
in the U.S.?
I guess it was Cubans a lot first
and then when that ended other,
players from other countries
started to come more?
>> Right, before the Castro
revolution Cuba had the largest
number of players born
outside the United States
that were in the majors.
I don't have the exact
number off the top of my head
but they were pretty much the main
producer of major league talent
in the, from Latin America.
And then once the Castro
revolution took over
and eventually professional
baseball was eliminated there
and ties were cut off so that
players couldn't come here,
that's when you started
to see the growth
in other Latin American countries,
specifically the Dominican Republic,
Venezuela and then Puerto Rico.
Today, the Dominican
is the largest producer
of major league talent followed
by Venezuela and then Puerto Rico.
When they do there, even though,
yes, they're U.S. citizens,
when Major League Baseball
does their sort of count their,
run their numbers they refer to it
as 'born outside the
50 United States'.
So that's how Puerto Rico gets
put into that list, again,
Latin America, much larger than the
Asian countries although they're
increasing now as well.
>> You said there were five
teams in the Cuban League and?
>> Four teams.
>> [Inaudible] yes,
Cienfuegos, Marianao.
>> Right.
>> Almendares' home field is
also in the greater Havana area?
>> Yeah, they used to,
earlier in the existence
of the Cuban League they had
sort of their own ballparks.
There was an Almendares Park.
There were Cienfuegos.
Matanzas had a park but then in
1933 and there's a photo here,
the La Tropical Stadium was
built for the Pan-American Games.
There's an aerial shot and
you'll see that there's actually
like a track intersecting
the baseball field.
So it was used for not only
baseball but track and field,
soccer and that's, and all the
four teams at that point played
in that one location,
in the Marianao area just
outside the heart of the city.
And then in 1946 right before
the season that my book focuses
on Bobby Maduro and his company
built El Gran Stadium in,
closer to the heart of the city.
Again, all four teams moved
to that area and it was
because the La Tropical while it
was supposedly this really wonderful
site because it was associated.
That's it right there.
It was associated with the breweries
so there were beer gardens,
dancehalls and all
these other activities
but it really wasn't
great for baseball.
So then they moved
to El Gran Stadium
and you can see a much
more traditional setup
for baseball, more capacity.
It could hold 34,000 when it opened.
There were lights added
to El Gran Stadium
which La Tropical did not have.
So because it, not only was the
economy booming post World War 11
but the old stadium simply really
couldn't hold the interest,
all the fans that were interested
and so the season that I talked
about is the inauguration of
that sort of more modern stadium.
>> Do teams still play
at El Gran Stadium?
>> They do.
If you saw where the Rays went
to play the Cuban National
Team and that's been.
That's El Gran Stadium.
It's called Estadio Latinoamericano
and it looks very similar.
The main change is that now
that there's a. I think you saw
in the aerial shot there were
no seats in the outfield.
Now they have.
They have grandstands and
bleachers in that area
so the capacity is much larger.
You know I believe that for that
game Major League Baseball helped
to sort of do not necessarily
renovations but maybe just upkeep.
Like much of Cuba's infrastructure
stuff had started to deteriorate
so they did, from my understanding,
did quite a bit to get it
up to standard for that game.
Yes?
>> You mentioned a
conflict with the,
because of the Mexican Leagues
sort of created problems
for Major League Baseball.
What brought about I guess
the big [inaudible] allow Cuba
to become part of the minor leagues?
>> Yeah, like the.
>> [Inaudible] after that.
>> Like one of the
things that happened,
there was actually an organized
baseball sanctioned Cuban League
that was running parallel to the
traditional one where players
who were afraid about
their future went to play.
But there were two attempts.
There was one attempt like that
and it just did not have the
popular support of fans and it ended
up finishing prematurely
that season in '46, '47.
And then eventually,
basically a delegation
from the Cuban League went and met
with organized baseball to come
up with an agreement to sort
of let the Cuban League back
into good graces but bring
them under the umbrella
of organized baseball
because of the fact that all
of these players suddenly didn't
have a career in the majors,
in organized baseball anymore, so
they were able to work a negotiated.
They negotiated a system
where, but now codified sort
of how the league would
be populated with players
from Major League Baseball,
what numbers,
what pool of players
they could pick from.
Previously to that, each Cuban
team just kind of signed players
who they had contacts with.
I mentioned Miguel Angel
Gonzalez, he was a coach with the,
a third-base coach for the
Cardinals for many years.
In fact he was in the
third-base coaching box
in the 1946 World Series for
Enos Slaughter's mad dash home.
But like Adolfo Luque
who was the manager
for Almendares he was a pitching
coach with the Giants at the time.
He recruited Sal Maglie
to come and play for him
when he was managing
Cienfuegos in the '45, '46 season
and that's how they kind of just
through their contacts in baseball,
that's how they signed players.
But moving forward after
the conflict with the,
because of the Mexican League
raids they set up a codified system
of how they would actually
be able to use players
from organized baseball
going forward.
>> But then there was also
like a Triple AAA team
in Havana in the 50s?
>> Right. It actually began as a
B-League team, the Havana Cubans
in 1946 and then Bobby Maduro who.
He built the stadium as well not
just to modernize the Cuban League
but also with an eye toward
eventually having a major league
team in Havana.
And he bought the Cubans
and in 1954 they then moved
to the internationally AAA
as the Havana Sugar Kings
and they were affiliated
with the Reds.
So by that point it was actually a,
you know that minor league
team operated separately
from the Cuban Winter League
but, you know that was.
They were affiliated
with the Reds like I said
but like the Cuban League was
brought into organized baseball
as an unaffiliated minor league
so they weren't you know,
in Triple AAA, Double
AA or what have you.
>> What can you tell us about
that picture of the Dodgers
with Hemingway and all [inaudible]?
>> Well, it's in the book during
the '41 and '42 seasons when,
before the Dodgers would train
there, spring training I mean.
You know Hemingway was
living in Havana at the time.
He had a ranch about 10 miles
outside of the city and he would run
into the players not just at
the ballparks but at the casinos
and nightclubs and invited a
group of them back to his farm
and I don't want to give everything
away but it involved quite a bit
of drinking, fisticuffs and
the challenge to a duel so.
John, did you have a question?
>> Yeah, I was wondering
if the Cuban League had
any international play
with other Latin American
countries on a regular basis?
>> No, not specifically.
There were Cuban players
who would go and play
in Venezuela or the Dominican.
In certain years, certainly also
players from those countries came
and played in the Cuban League.
During the time when the Cuban
League was an outlaw league,
there were discussions about
maybe creating some sort
of Latin American League, where
they would play against teams
from other Latin American countries.
It never really got off the ground.
It was more or less just trying to
figure out what are we going to do
if we're not, you know, if we're
still sort of this rogue league?
But no, there were never really
sort of organized games other
than maybe exhibition games.
Yes?
>> This, this obviously
is outside the purview
of the title of your book.
Could you maybe talk a
little bit about how baseball
in Cuba changed after
the revolution?
I think, I mean we obviously had
a lot of American influence prior
to the revolution but we do know
that baseball has survived
in Cuba [inaudible].
>> Yeah, it survived and
even thrived on some levels.
One of the major changes
obviously the major change is,
no professionalism.
It became state-run just like
all the businesses and, but,
for instance in this
era where all the teams,
the four teams even though they may
have by name represented other parts
of the country, they all played
all their games in Havana.
And what they did post-revolution
was they spread the league out,
throughout the country.
And in fact there were
rules that you had to live.
You had to be from that province
to play on that province's team.
And so that's, it's
called the Serie Nacional,
the National Series is what
it is now and that league was,
with the pool of players
that they would use
to fill the Cuban national team.
And obviously for international
amateur competitions they were the
dominant force for decades
whether it was Olympics,
their version of a World Cup
played throughout the country,
throughout the world.
They were the team to beat.
That has not necessarily
been the case in recent years
because they have haemorrhaged so
much talent through defections,
particularly the last,
maybe ten years
or so they have seen a huge spike in
defections and you see the results
of that with the players that
are coming to the major leagues
and making an immediate impact,
you know, whether it's [inaudible]
or Horayu [phonetic] or [inaudible],
Chapman who was mentioned earlier.
And there's a player on the Red
Sox system, Moncada who is supposed
to be just a star and
he's in his early 20s.
So now that [inaudible] it's
not necessarily the case
that they're just going to be
the automatic winner and I think
that that at least in part is
what has kind of helped drive the,
at least on the baseball
side, the connections
that are being made right now with
Cuba and Major League Baseball.
The Cuban government I'm sure wants
to, if there is going to be a future
where Cuban players can come to the
majors, they want it to be some kind
of a system where they can maintain
some control over their players
so that they're not all defecting.
>> Could you talk a
little bit about Dihigo,
the guy who is in three
Halls of Fame?
>> Yeah, Martin Dihigo,
there are photos of him here.
He played in the Negro
Leagues in the 1920s.
Many consider him to be maybe
the greatest all-around player,
certainly in Cuba maybe anywhere.
He played practically every
position and he was a great pitcher.
He was a great hitter.
But because he was
black he never played
in the majors but that didn't.
He was elected to the Hall of Fame
by the Veterans Committee along
with many other Negro
Leaguers during the 1970s.
And he was a manager
in Cuba as well.
He managed also in other
Latin American countries
and as you mentioned, in the Hall of
Fame in the U.S., Cuba and Mexico,
a terrific player but never got
the chance to show that here other
than playing for Negro
League teams or barnstorming
with Negro League teams
in the United States.
And he's a contemporary of Adolfo
Luque and Miguel Angel Gonzalez,
you know, but because they were
white they could play in the majors.
>> Can you talk a little bit
about the experience of attending,
of being a fan in the 40s in Cuba?
Were there tickets
that you had to buy?
What were the prices?
Did they sell popcorn?
I'm sure they didn't
but like what was the?
Did you dress up because I
think it used to be more formal?
>> Yeah, there's a, "Life" magazine
did a. I found pictures from 1951
and everybody, they did a
huge spread, multiple photos
and you see everybody in suits
and ties and their best dresses
which I find amazing considering
what the temperature must have been
even though it was.
Even though it was
January and February
in Cuba it was very festive.
There were bands or at
least groups of people
with instruments in the stands.
You would see there are
[inaudible] images of guys walking
around with these giant
lottery billboards
that they would sell there.
People would place bets on the
first homerun, the first hit.
So it's a fairly festive atmosphere
and in all the readings I've done
The Sporting News did a great job
covering the Cuban League back then.
And it was unlike any
atmosphere that they had,
that those writers had seen
in Major League Baseball.
Yes?
>> Will Oscar [inaudible]
as well but I've heard,
I think there are rumors that,
obviously I think Fidel Castro,
he's confirmed he's a big baseball
fan but I've heard some things
about he was actually
a prospect at one time?
>> Largely urban myth [laughter].
>> I heard that too [laughter].
>> Yeah, it's the kind of
thing that started and sort
of subsequent writers just
picked up on and it just kind
of kept growing but they're.
He played I believe
volleyball and basketball
at the University of Havana.
One author, Roberto Gonzalez
Echevarria, he wrote a great book,
sort of the entire scope of Cuban
baseball history called "Pride
of Havana" and he actively
sought out box scores trying
to find evidence of a
Fidel Castro and only found
that one, F. Castro, pitching.
I'm presently working on, sort
of the next book which is the end
of professional baseball and
where I've seen the references,
apparently start is with
Joe Cambria who was a scout
for the Washington Senators and
signed something on the order
of 300 players from Cuba
throughout the 30s, 40s and 50s
and he's the one who sort of
said that Castro was a prospect
and you know that if
he had been able
to sign him maybe things
would have been different.
And then some other writers
just picked up on it.
It became almost a fact
but there's no evidence.
And I don't know if you're
familiar with the name Ralph Avila.
He was the guy kind of
running the Dodgers' academies
in the Dominican Republic and he,
I spoke to him several months ago
and he was just adamant that that's.
There's just no truth to
that and he was apparently
with Castro before the revolution,
you know, while it was happening,
for a time before being
against the revolution,
once he saw what it was
actually going to be.
So, yeah, my guess is that maybe
Cambria kind of said that in a way
of maybe ingratiating himself
with Castro because he wanted to,
I think at that point, at that time,
the relationships were starting
to deteriorate between the U.S and
Cuba and I'm sure he was just hoping
to be able to keep signing talent
on the cheap in Cuba going forward
and maybe that's why he
sort of made him sound
like a better baseball
player than he was or even.
Anyone else?
>> I have like 5 million.
>> Sure [laughter], we have time.
>> If you talk a little bit
more about Jackie Robinson.
I don't know if he's ever talked
about his experience in Cuba.
Was he just there that one time?
What, you kind of allude
to, it changes things.
Everything changes after that
so, if you could talk about?
>> Yeah, I mean that was the
only time that he played there,
that spring training
and as I said it was
because Rickey wanted the more
tolerant social climate in Havana
as the sort of staging ground
for his elevation to the majors.
But it was not at all guaranteed
that he was going to make it
to the majors that
season and he had the.
And in some of the slides
it kind of alludes to it,
he had to deal with several issues.
He had. He was changing position.
For the second time actually, he was
a shortstop in the Negro Leagues.
He played second base with the
Royals in the International League
and was the league's MVP in '46
and suddenly was handed
a first baseman's mitt
and because the Dodgers'
infield was essentially stacked.
That was the only spot that
potentially he could break
into so he had to deal with that.
There was, even though
Cuba was chosen
for the better racial
climate he still had to deal
with separate accommodations.
The Dodgers were at the Hotel
Nacional which is a landmark,
this opulent hotel and the
Montreal Royals trained
at the Havana Military Academy about
10 or 15 miles outside the city.
It's not at all unusual for a minor
league and a major league team
to have different accommodations,
it still happens today.
But in addition to that, Robinson
and the other three black players
were housed in a pretty seedy hotel
in Old Havana so they
were even separate
from their Montreal teammates
probably out of Rickey,
an abundance of caution
although kind of unnecessary.
Robinson had played a
year with the Royals.
There were no issues with teammates.
Whatever issues they encountered
were when they played other teams.
As I said he was the International
League MVP so it was an odd choice
and it, and Robinson
was not happy about it.
There was also, he
had an injury late,
a minor injury late
in spring training.
Leo Durocher largely was
absent during spring training
because he was dealing with
multiple issues including his sort
of scandalous marriage
to actress Laraine Day.
But also there was, he had
been admonished by Chandler
to disassociate himself from
gamblers which he had done in Cuba
but he and Rickey raised a stink
when there were gamblers seen
in the Yankees President's
Box at Gran Stadium.
And there were hearings with
Chandler during spring training
so Robinson, so Durocher
hardly ever got
to see Robinson during
spring training.
So there were quite a few
things that, quite a few issues
that Robinson had to
deal with not the least
of which was the petition started by
a group of Dodgers' players to try
and prevent him from actually
making it to the majors.
And all that boiled over
on a side trip to Panama
which is explained in the book.
Yes?
>> One picture [inaudible] is just
opposite Satchel Paige who's got a
legendary reputation in
baseball everywhere [inaudible].
>> Right.
>> Any particular stories that come
out about him being,
playing in Cuba?
>> Yeah, he played for Santa Clara
which was one of the earlier teams
in the Cuban League and I don't
want to give the whole thing away
but yes, there was an issue
where he essentially had
to get out of Cuba because he.
There are sort of conflicting
stories.
What it was.
>> It didn't involve
Hemingway did it?
>> That, those didn't involve
Hemingway but it was either
because he didn't understand,
like the, whatever the mayor
of that particular city was upset
with one of his performances
and asked him if he
had basically thrown it
and him not understanding Spanish,
sort of nodded and just smiled
which enraged the mayor or
it was supposedly because he,
of a relationship with
a woman there.
A lot of conflicting stories,
they're all sort of explained
and you can try and figure out
which one is the actual truth but.
>> And Josh Gibson?
>> Ah Josh.
>> Could you give a little?
>> Sure, he also played for Santa
Clara for a couple of seasons
and he led the league in homeruns.
Not surprisingly down there,
you know, shorter season,
I think it was something like
eight homeruns or whatever but well
over a 300 batting average.
You know, that was a very common
thing for Negro League players
to play down there whether it was
barnstorming during the winter
or playing with Cuban League
teams and that was something
that was going on again
since like 1900.
Every year there would be
teams that came through.
It became known as the American
Series whether it was Negro League
teams barnstorming there or
major league teams or a semblance
of major league teams,
All-Star teams barnstorming
and then the spring
training games as well.
Yeah?
>> Are there any sort of
unique baseball traditions
in Cuba back then?
I mean we have the
seventh-inning stretch.
We have, you know, rally
caps, things like that.
Is there anything that you need to,
the Cuban history any other things?
>> Well, maybe just the atmosphere,
just the sort of open betting
on everything from first
homerun to first hit or whatever.
That was certainly a big deal there.
There were also like awards handed,
like money awards to the players,
like if somebody got a no-hitter.
Bohemia magazine would pay out,
you know $1000 or whatever it was
or $500 so there were
those types of things,
were like a big accomplishment
would actually get,
be a. There would be a cash reward
for the player from a magazine
or whoever happened to be
sponsoring that sort of thing.
Yes?
>> Were the players down there
able to play professionally
and not have another job or did
they have to work during the season
or work in the off-season?
>> Well, a lot of them
would play in the majors
or in Minor League Baseball in
the summer or they'd go to play
in Mexico in the summer
and then be playing
in their homeland during
winter ball.
So they kind of were able
to play baseball year round
and that was also why they were
able to get American players to come
down there, you know, because if
you weren't a star player once the
baseball season ended you kind
of needed to get a job, you know,
whether it was working at
the local hardware store
or whatever for the winter.
So, if they had the
opportunity to go down to Cuba
or Dominican Republic or
Puerto Rico and play baseball
and earn money they
didn't have to go
and get a real job
during those times so.
But yeah, the Cuban players were
probably playing baseball year round
whether in the minors,
other Latin countries
or in Major League Baseball.
There was another question?
>> I was just wondering if any of
the players that visited Cuba stayed
or returned and settled down.
Are there any stories like that?
>> I'm trying to think if
anything along those lines.
I've read stories about
some players,
some of the Negro League
players staying in Mexico.
I don't recall any
American players sort
of staying beyond just the winter.
Again a lot of them had
their lives and careers here.
They were in the majors but they
all seemed to, reading quotes
and the people I've
talked to all seemed
to really enjoy their
time down there.
Because it was, they were well paid.
They played baseball and they
didn't have to play every day.
They would play games maybe three,
maybe four days a week so they had
down time where they could go to the
nightclubs or hang out on the beach.
>> What were the comparative
economics
of U.S. baseball versus
Cuban baseball?
I mean was it, was there?
I mean there's obviously,
you know, you can't even,
you know, compare it to today.
It was different here.
>> Right, right.
>> But.
>> I mean I've heard, read
stories and heard from people
that they would make more money
a month playing baseball in Cuba
than they were getting paid a
month playing in the majors.
So from that standpoint it was
certainly a good thing for them.
I believe at that time it was a one
to one ratio in terms of dollars
and pesos so it translated
really well obviously.
So yeah it was, economically
it was a good thing
for the players to come down there.
>> Was it viewed?
Was winter ball in Cuba
viewed as a good time
for the major league
baseball players?
Is that one of the reasons why?
>> Sure.
>> Yeah, we were just kind of
saying women and rum and gambling
and baseball three
or four days a week.
>> All of the above [laughter].
I mean yeah, this was the nightlife
where there was nightclubs,
casinos was a big draw.
Cuba really became sort of the, a
playground for American tourists
and baseball players
were part of that.
I mentioned the Hotel Nacional.
When it opened you know the guest
list are movie stars and boxers
and from the United States, so yes
and this particular time period
in the late 1940s the
mob is just starting
to get entrenched down there.
In fact, right before the Dodgers
went to stay at the Hotel Nacional
for the 1947 spring training,
a couple weeks before there had been
a, for lack of a better description,
a mob convention led by Meyer Lansky
where they were trying to plot
out how they were going
to divvy up the casinos.
They all had interests in various
casinos and hotels and nightclubs
to make it essentially the
Las Vegas of the Caribbean,
away from the prying eyes
of U.S. law enforcement.
Yes?
>> I guess.
There was also going on
a lot of people would,
a lot of Americans would
be [inaudible] Key West,
hop on the ferry and do their
honeymoon in Havana and Cuba.
Was there a, during this winter,
were there a lot of Americans going
to Cuban winter ball as, you know,
fans down there or was it, you know,
was it primarily a Cuban fan
base and that's what you did.
Were the Americans
staying in the casinos?
>> Yeah, I suspect there was
probably mostly a Cuban fan base.
You mentioned the ferries.
I know the players
would do exactly that.
They'd get, go down to Florida,
take the ferry and their car
on the ferry, to come to
Havana to play in the winter.
But I suspect that the large
percentage of the fans going
to these games were Cuban fans.
Anybody else?
Tracy, any more questions
[laughter]?
>> [Inaudible].
Can you talk a little bit more
about your next project you started
to talk about, to tell us about?
>> Yeah, I've already
started interviewing.
I've clocked about a
dozen interviews so far
and I'm gathering newspaper
articles, trying to focus on the end
of professional baseball in Cuba,
essentially sort of 1958 to 1961,
what happened with the Cuban
League and the Sugar Kings at the,
you know, as the revolution
was building and then
in the immediate aftermath
of the revolution.
How the league ended, you know,
the last season was 1960-61
for the Cuban League and it was
an all-Cuban for the first time,
certainly in the 20th
century, an all-Cuban League
because U.S. players
were not allowed
at that point to come and play.
And the Sugar Kings had to leave
mid-season in 1960 to Jersey City
and it was abrupt enough
that when they debuted
in Jersey City they still had
their Sugar Kings uniforms
on with a patch stitched on across
the chest that said Jersey City.
It was in July when they moved,
when essentially the International
League revoked the franchise
and they had to relocate.
>> I feel like it's unfair
to put you on the spot
but what does happen now with the
thawing of relations between U.S.
and Cuba, will we see more players?
Will there be a professional
league again?
Or right now I guess the only
institutionalized baseball is
through the national team?
>> Right. Well, I think
we're going to see some sort
of system in place eventually.
How long that will
take I don't know.
I can tell you that there's
a group here, people who used
to be associated with the
Pawtucket Red Sox who own the rights
to a future minor league team in
Havana should there ever be one.
They've been working to build
relationships with the people
in Cuba, the officials
there, you know,
but right now they're just kind of.
They're just building relationships
in case there is an opportunity.
How exactly that would play out
given the economics of the country,
given the embargo still being in
place, yet to be seen I suspect
as far as Cuban players playing in
the majors and not having to defect,
I think we will see something.
Maybe it will be a system similar to
what we see with the Japanese League
where a major league team will
essentially bid for the right
to negotiate with a player,
whatever pool of players
that they make available and then
if they negotiate a
contract I suspect part
of that money will go back
to the Cuban government
and they will have some sort
of control over his services.
Cuba had already started sort of
allowing veteran players to play
in Japan after, you know sort
of as a reward for playing,
for a distinguished career and not
defecting [laughter] from Cuba.
So, but usually they've
been late in their careers
and have not necessarily
had the kind of impact
that certainly Major League
Baseball would be looking
for so yes, I think it will happen.
I think there might still be a
ways away although the one thing
that made me think it might happen
quicker was the goodwill tour
that baseball took in
December I think it was
where they went to Cuba.
And but what they brought with them,
they brought defectors with them,
Yasuo Fujii was there and at the
time I just found that stunning.
These are players that were declared
traitors because they left Cuba
and suddenly they were able
to travel back there freely
with this goodwill tour.
You know and the Cuban
government, I mean if they wanted.
If they want to save baseball in
Cuba they need to do something
to stop the defections or
have more control over this
because that's what's been
hurting baseball there.
And if they can come
up with a system
where they can control
the players or which,
and I would imagine there would have
to be some sort of a restriction
on anybody who defects
actually playing then.
I don't know how that
would work out either so,
there's a lot of questions but I
do think that it's just a matter
of time before we do see it.
>> I think it's important to note
also that there are Cuban defectors
in the minor leagues in the U.S.
>> Yes.
>> [Inaudible] all over the world.
>> Yeah and that's the thing
is that not all of them,
a vast majority just
like which is the case
for not just American minor leaguers
but Dominican minor leaguers.
It's a tiny fraction of the
folks that are in the minors
that actually make it to the majors.
So for yeah, for every Yasuo
Fujii, there's dozens if not more
who just have, never
make it out of the minors
or never even make it to the minors.
>> One more question, someone's
got that one last question.
What is it?
Who's it going to be, alright,
[laughter] thank you so much.
>> Thank you.
>> Victor Brioso.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov